la société de sauvetage du québec a
recensé trente et une noyade en date
d'hier c'est 9 de plus qu'à pareille
date l'an dernier un arc md directeur
général de l'organisation
on le retrouve maintenant c'est notre
rencontre annuelle sur monsieur aucune
instance i way dit tout c'est triste
j'en reviens pas comment se fait-il que
bague normalement quoi ces 22 23 ce
temps ci de l'année et la c31 qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est à dire comment on
explique sans ben je vous expliquerai je
veux pas venir minimisé ces incidents
lamé et rappelez-vous qu'en début
d'année ça a été quand même assez rude
avec les motoneigistes qu'on a perdu le
les européens le guide du québec la dent
région de saguenay lac saint jean
ça faisait déjà six décès liés à l'eau
et les trois mortels picon de rencontrer
au cours du dernier week-end avec
l'accident de moto marine fait en sorte
qu'on peut venir expliquer le principe
mathématique que je viens de vous
élaborez ou non de plus mais il reste
que lorsqu'on a des vagues de chaleur
comme on a connu au cours des dernières
journées
les gens veulent aller sur les
différents cours d'eau ont aussi nos
sceptiques ne démontre 40% à rivière 30%
lac alors ça ça joue un peu contre nous
lorsqu'il fait très beau parce que plus
de gens prennent l'eau sur l'eau dans
l'eau et le dernier week-end n'a pas
fait exception à l'heure pour justement
ces décès liés à nous qu'on a rencontrés
ont seulement si le confinement le
télétravail le fait qu'on était en
cabane et dès qu'il fait beau on se
précipite à tout crin pour aller sur
l'eau peut-être que les enfants aussi
que sont pas l'école ne sont plus auto
des piscines vous avez raison vous savez
on a un accroissement du nombre de
piscines résidentielles qui ont été
vendus cette année parce que le
confinement la pandémie fait en sorte
que les gens veulent passer leur été
dans leur cour le télétravail semble
avoir été un facteur déterminant pour
deux états l'état de la floride et hutch
d'exar ce et c'est pour ça que nous on a
déjà commencé à sensibiliser la
population
c'est pas parce que j'amène mes enfants
à la baignade que ce soit la raison
secondaire loup dans ma cour arrière
avec médecine plus que jamais de mon
portable avec moi que j'ai le temps de
surveiller et de vouloir faire monter le
travail sa vie le phénomène de la noyade
chez les jeunes enfants c'est un
phénomène silencieux qu'ils avaient
seconde n'avait pas le temps de répondre
un courriel donc comprenez le principe
du sauveteur désigné vous savez au
québec on a bien compris le conducteur
désigné maintenant on va adopter le
sauveteur désigné afin de justement
demandé une personne responsable de
surveiller constamment le temps que je
passe le télétravail ici je suis seul
mais vaut mieux prendre des poses de
baignade
il dira aux enfants un peu comme on le
ferait avec la rue tu peux pas aller
jouer dans la rue sans la surveillance
d'un adulte c'est le même principe avec
le plan d'eau qu'on ne leur cour arrière
oui j'entends des monsieurs cette
semaine de québec qui dit écoutez moi
c'est pas compliqué sur des enfants dans
la cour avec la piscine est accessible
je suis dans la piscine je suis là c'est
le même principe
finalement le meilleur moyen d'assurer
une certaine sécurité
oui et on s'organise aussi pour ne pas
être distrait par le portable le
téléphone en vrai j'ai lu ou sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'il ya une maman que
dit mon enfant peut pas aller se baigner
cheptel personne parce qu'elle est
constamment sans prise sur son téléphone
alors on comprend que la distraction
peut être un facteur déterminant ces
distractions la belle est causée par
quoi part justement les moyens
électroniques honda et le télétravail a
pas d'appareil il n'y a pas
d'application n'ya pas d'accessoires qui
compense pour une surveillance je pense
à ces objets qui flottent et qui est
s'ils ressentent drôle drôle grandes
vagues vont vont s'activer parce qu'un
enfant tombe à l'eau le sel ou avertis
sur le téléphone iriez qui compense une
paire de jeu bah écoutez moi c'est ce
que j'appelle des dispositifs
additionnel mais il reste la meilleure
personne pour pouvoir surveiller ses
enfants ça sera cette personne là qu'on
aura à clé sont retardés signé et on
fait des rotations comme vous voyez dans
les plages publiques les piscines
publiques ont fait des rotations entre
les parents ou les personnes
responsables et là si jamais vous fera
humblement ne jamais prendre pour acquis
que quelqu'un d'autre quand votre place
donc ça c'est vraiment clair vous devez
assumer cette responsabilité est sûre
que ce soit au lac au chalet ou encore
alexine résidentiel est encore plus vrai
si vous allez fréquenter des plages
publiques ou des piscines publiques
il ya une responsabilité que vous
appartient à vous aussi bien 10h15 merci
beaucoup c'est bon de vous parler ce
sera agréable si j'avais pas des
statistiques comme celle là mais c'est
la réalité pour faire de la prévention
merci beaucoup au revoir bonne journée
au revoir